Zoom call. Welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
Hunter questions came in. So let's
jump right into it.
Revided to look on the member site. We have a question about
the
new commenter.
This is a good
better
but any new commenter will work. You can buy what at Target
or you all greens or something or you can order it on Amazon.
They're not very expensive.
And would it be advisable that everybody checks their glucose?
Maybe, maybe not. Again, you know, I don't want, you know, here,
you know, it depends on the person. So it, um,
you know,
I think, yeah, I think, you know, at the last you could feed the
cancer, the better off your, even, you have to have that balance on
what's going to bring you anxiety before it ought to, too. So
we'll just necessarily one more thing to do.
But check who goes can be beneficial. There's information on the
member site about that.
Remember, you have access to the courses and all the blog posts.
I do want to touch on this again this week.
It's right. You can send out an email, say that version 6.2,
now it's up to 6.4. So 6.4 is the version that's the current
running version.
But version 6.1, 6.2 and 6.4 is different than what
all of you have. I think, I think everybody on this call is
running 6.0. And, but those that started with us in the last few
weeks are running 6.1, 6.2 or 6.4, 6.4 just came out this week.
Now, there's issues with these. So don't think that you have to
upgrade. I do think that they are going to be improvements, but
there's some, there's some tweaks to it. You have to get to your
program a different way. If you go and talk, call to write, and
they upgrade your version to 6.1, 2, or 4, you will lose the
programs that I created for you.
And that's going to be a problem, obviously. So don't do that. If
you want to upgrade to a higher version, then please contact
us and you'll have to ship your computer back to us. And I will
have to upgrade you to the new software and put your programs
back up. And then they go on a little bit differently. You don't
see them in the main screen. The, as you open up the open home
program screen, you have to go to documents and then find your
program. So it's a little bit trickier. I do have a video on how to
get to your programs with the 6.1, 2, or 4 software. This is how
you would do it. I'm not going to go over it. This is on the
member's side. So let's get to the questions. First of all, does
anyone know of a good oncologist in the Atlanta area? We have
a patient that's moving to that area and wants to go to an
oncologist down there and find somebody who's open to, you
know, alternative-minded things, or at least open to, you know,
doing what the patient wants to do, not pushing a person just
towards what their protocols are. So please email me if you do
know anybody, if anybody's listening now, you can chat
in it, but otherwise email me so I can inform that person. I
appreciate that. Okay, how many days should someone back off
taking their antioxidants after receiving chemo? Are there any
other supplements that should be withheld for a time? So I do
have a blog post about this that gives you some general
considerations. Now, understand there are a lot of alternative
practitioners that say, don't back off at all doing antioxidants.
Don't change your supplement protocol at all. So, you know, you do
want to pray about it. You know, my belief is that, you know,
chemo is a strong as a strong oxidizing agent. And you know,
you want it to work as best as possible. So I do think you
should lay off your antioxidants at least for 48 hours. And
are there other supplements that should be withheld? Maybe you
could lay off all your supplements for 48 hours. There wouldn't
be any problem with that at all. You don't want to be doing a
lot of strong detox for that 48 hours because you want to
chemo to stay in you for that 48 hours and work and kill the
cancer. So you would not be a miss at just stayed off of
everything for 48 hours after that chemo. And if you're going
to do a fast prior to the chemo, you may stay off everything
during that 24 or 48 hour fast prior to the chemo. There is
nothing wrong with doing that. But I also don't think that
there's necessarily anything wrong with the approach and
other practitioners taken not to get weight off anything at
all. You just need to pray about that. My personal feeling is,
if I was going to do the chemo, I would go off the antioxidants
during my fast prior to the chemo. And then for 48 hours after
the chemo. And I wouldn't do any coffee enemas. And I would
do strong detox support and layoff of that. So I may actually lay
off of everything for that 48 hour window. And then you can go
back. A few weeks ago, I began taking black sand blood. So
black sand blood is a capsule supplement that has granola and
black sand and some other things in it per year recommendation
three times a day about 10 days after the first dose also
took water edema and had dead parasites in it. This caused me
to ask some questions. First, should I take a medizol for three
days in addition to blood root to kill any parasites? Or will
the blood root kill the parasites alone? So the parasites are
not giving you black sand blood root to kill parasites. So I
do not, I have never recommended a blood root for the purpose
of killing parasites and recommending the black sand blood root
for the purpose of helping your body kill cancer cells. So
that is the purpose of now. It is a half things in there that
can't help kill parasites. Sure. Can you take fed medizol
with black sand blood root? Yes, you can. If you're not
currently taking fed medizol, should you take it just because
you saw the parasites? I wouldn't know. If that's part of your
protocol, then I would stay on it and follow your protocol. Is
there a conflict of taking fed medizol and black sand blood
root at the same time? No. And should I stop taking any other
supplements before taking fed medizol? No. So you can take
fed medizol with all your other supplements as well. I read that
you aren't supposed to get IV vitamin C impusions if you're
taking Pectusol C. Can you explain? Can I just not take the
Pectusol C the day I get vitamin C? So I don't recommend this.
So I recommend that you take that you don't, I do not
recommend that you omit Pectusol when you're doing IV
vitamin C. Now, you can certainly upon, you know, what other
practitioners request, not take the Pectusol C the day that
you're doing the vitamin C IV. But I have never actually told
somebody to not take Pectusol C even the day that they're
taking the IV vitamin C. So I don't see the big conflict. I
think some of the research that it's not going to work as well
if you're taking IV vitamin C. But it's just the day that
remember, you take IV vitamin C. If you do take any
vitamins and have a half length in your body and it's going
to discreet quite quickly. So question of the cheek swam
the supplements from another practitioner. Do you agree with
the dose? So I didn't test the dose of those things. When
you get supplements from another practitioner, I don't
test the dose on that. That's up to your other practitioner
who choose to take that. I just test whether it, whether
I think it is advisable to case take that's whether a test
negative or positive. That's all I test when I test
another practitioner or something. You know, you can't
talk a lot about bags, but the men and dissolved, which is the
human cord of the Ben Ben dissolved is so expensive is Ben
Ben OK to take. We do have to look at the dose and equivalent
ice. It's 112 milligrams or something of the human
equivalent of that Ben dissolved. So yeah, I've never looked at
price difference for that. I don't think that the product
itself is that I could be wrong on it. I don't think the product
itself is any different. I think they're in the exact same
product. They just sold other different labels. So I think
you would be fine. That's my opinion. You think all the
reactions I had to the mistletoe could raise my liver and
that I'm so fast. The answer is yes, for sure. So anything
that causes an inflammatory reaction can raise your liver
enzymes actually pretty immediately. So yes, that's a very
big possibility. Yes, I've settings were OK. I did test
that from your cheek. So if I didn't change your right settings,
but it's in you a flash drive that there is no need to change
sometimes I could put no need to change right setting, sometimes
I don't actually type that. So you might not see. But if I need
to change on the cheek swab, you asked me to check your right
settings. I for sure did. And if I don't send you a flash drive
in there, there was no change. Can you comment on my chest
X-ray? Yeah, it was pretty but not so that your X-ray
what didn't show any horribly gross abnormalities. There was
some possible fluid and that's why the radiologist what he
uses those kind of obtuse words that that are difficult to
understand. It's because he can't be specific because there's
blurred margins and things like that that words that he used. It's
because fluids in there. So that I think you did send me
another question saying that you had a half liter taken off
your lung today, which is great and that will make you feel
better. I will, you know, is it word? Maybe this will be a word
of encouragement to this person. I've had people that have
had five liters of fluid and more taken off their abdominal
cavity and three more taken off their lung. So half a liter
isn't a lot of fluid that's built up. So that's actually a
good sign that is that that you got that taken out that you
don't get instantly from that. And it's a good sign that it
wasn't as much as your original thinking possible too. I
haven't had much cheese for such a long time but I'm
craving cheese. What am I missing? Well, I don't adhere to
philosophy that just because you're craving something that you
were always depleted in something. I crave cupcakes and I don't
think I have a deficiency in cupcakes. So it's that's not
always the case. So is it possible? Yeah, is it possible that
you're deficient in some minerals or something that you
would get from cheese? Maybe, but you are taking minerals. So I
doubt it. So I don't think it's I would always equate it to when
you're craving something that you're deficient in something.
I'm not he craved chemo pills. One of the side effects is
elevated glucose. You have he taking less burberry. Do we just keep
an eye on this? Yes. Yeah, let's just keep an eye on that.
In the testing, you came up with I think I dropped your burberry
down to one of the or something like that. I talked to my other
doctor that did the singotera test in June. It was over 1200 and
September was down to 550. Well, that's huge good news.
There's always silver lights and everything that's going on. So that's
good. While looking at options for breast cancer
treatments become apparent at a mastectomy, this is for
this person. Of my left breast would require a skin transfer
from my stomach to close the wound. So sometimes people don't have
enough flesh. The breast might be really small,
and they need to do a skin graft to close the wound.
Would a skin transfer trigger unwanted cell growth like
elective surgeries we talked about last week? Well,
any surgery is going to stimulate your body to need to heal from that
wound. So you just have to do what you have to do. So I think
having the lung surgery, they'll do the skin graft immediately to close that
wound. Yeah, I wouldn't hesitate to do that. You need
that one hesitate to do that. I've always had trouble detoxifying.
For the last two and a half years, I've been doing one to three
coffee enemas per day, which means I haven't had a
valve without an animal. Should I be concerned about that?
Should I back off the enemas and try different supplements to see if my body
will produce a little valve of it, if so which supplements do you
recommend? No, I wouldn't be concerned about that.
There is nothing wrong. The whole thing is that you have to be
limiting. If you're using coffee enemas on a daily basis, you're not
using them for the purpose of having the bowel movement.
You're using coffee enemas for the purpose of
stimulating your parasympathetics so that you
get all the benefits from that. That's going to help stimulate your liver
function. That's going to help clone your body. That's going to help decrease
anxiety. That's going to help decrease blood pressure. That's going to help
stimulate immune response. All these wonderful things that's stimulating
the vaginal nerve by doing a coffee animal. That's the whole purpose of it.
Beside effect, you could say I'm doing a coffee enemas, that it can stimulate
a bowel movement, but you're not doing coffee enemas for the purpose of doing
bowel movements. If you're getting stuff out of your body, if you're
having a bowel movement, whether you're using a coffee enemas or not,
that's all we care about. I don't care if you're having normal
quote unquote bowel movements without coffee enemas or not. Don't be concerned
about that. I'd stay on track with what you're doing.
You're doing so well doing with the coffee enemas. I would not change that
once. After a recent cheek swab, you recommend an increase in protein,
one gram per ideal body weight in clones today. Should I decrease fat
and or carbohydrates with this change in protein?
Well, you are going to be increasing calorie, so if you're
gaining too much weight, then that's an issue and you do want to decrease
carbohydrates, but that'll dig anybody in my patient base has that issue.
It's the purpose of decreasing carbohydrates would be to decrease your blood
glucose levels and decrease the fuel supply that a cancer might have.
So, no, if you're at normal body weight or a healthy body weight or if you're
under body weight, I wouldn't change anything.
As far as you're fat or carbohydrate consumption goes,
if your glucose is high and if you're eating too many carbohydrates, so that's a
different story. If you're under body weight, then you really can't decrease
carbohydrates at all. So, I would just try to increase that protein with
those changes. So, there's a lot of ifs in that answer,
but it depends on where your body weight is, where you're coming into this,
what your body weight is. Does the source of protein plant for
animal matter? Yes or no, there's nothing wrong with getting as much protein as
you kids through plant sources. It's just,
is a person able to get it up protein through non-animal sources?
It would be difficult, honestly. Is it necessary? Is it better to only get
play a protein? I don't think so, no. There's benefits to
animal protein. There's benefits for your red blood cells.
There's blood benefits for platelet count to get some animal protein in.
It's just a matter of having that balance and having good quality animal protein,
cooking the grass fed beef. It's so much better, so much more nutrient
dense and has good fats, good omega-3s in it versus
grain fed animals. So, try to get grass fed beef as best you can.
I know bone broth is not recommended due to the glutamate content.
Are both collagen and gelatin okay and do they qualify as a good source of
protein? Or would you recommend your protein powder instead?
Well, I don't recommend necessarily recommend any protein powder because any
protein powder you're going to get is only going to be 20 grams of protein.
And then there's a lot of filling up point on in that. Whereas if we eat a piece of
chicken, you're probably getting, you know, 40 to 50 grams of protein,
which is just as much filling up going on. So,
I don't, you know, and I just think that might be a better
bang for the buck if you can. Now, if you're using a protein powder,
I'd recommend the protein powder that we have because it's low in glutamate.
But back to the question about collagen and gelatin. Is collagen
the gelatin okay? The answer is yes, but you have to be careful with it.
Collagen can have glutamated it. I don't know the content depends on the type of
collagen that you're using. But collagen does have other
possible issues with autoimmune issues. It's not that uncommon.
Yeah, so you might want to test it. So, I mean, do you feel better or worse when
you're taking collagen? So, try to, you know, ask that question
with collagen. It's not that, there is a way I ask, it's not that uncommon for you
to develop anybody's collagen tissue. We see that with autoimmune patients.
I mean, it's not super common, but it is a possibility. So, do watch and see if you
have any reaction and inflame increase inflammation
to collagen. Gelatin two, so if you needed to know these things,
collagen is tested on the Cyrex array five and gelatin is tested on the Cyrex
ten. Those are just possibilities. So, just be careful of that.
Don't try to look if you're taking those things. Make sure you note if you're
increasing inflammation after you take them. You mentioned the glucometer
pass. So, Miles, do you recommend one for each of us?
Should we all be trying to keep our glucose levels below 80?
Well, the answer to that is yes and no. I don't think everybody has to do
everything. It depends on the person. So, I just, you know,
talked to somebody that I think is on this call that we talked about just
just kind of laying off on that. Don't get too anxious about
measuring glucose levels. That could cause anxiety with some people.
So, we don't want to do that. We don't want you to be
anybody to be so hung up by their diet that they have
anxiety around it. You do your best to eat the best you can
and to follow a protocol without making it
a god in your life. And you know, that sounds awful, but we can tend to do that
with things. Especially when we have serious illness, we can get a little
obsessive about stuff. And I don't want you to get obsessive
about measuring your glucose levels on a daily basis either. So,
yeah, I have a glucometer. I often do I check my glucose, not very often.
So, and why? Because I don't obsess about
those things. I've said in the past, my diet is
probably worse than everybody that's on this call. That doesn't
mean that's the right thing to do, but that's not something I
obsess about. And, you know, what I feel convicted
about eating something or something. I'm consuming that I just
back off on it and try to get back in balance. It's a lot of times I go
out of balance the wrong way, but for the for I don't it's easy for
some people to become out of balance in an obsessive way. I don't want you to do
that because that just leads to anxiety and anxiety. What does
anxiety do to us? The anxiety just shuts down our parasympathetics.
So, and we need our parasympathetics to detoxify. We need our parasympathetics to
have a healthy immune response. That's the whole idea. And that really is the
whole idea about trying to increase your protein levels
because if those are your building blocks for your lymphocytes and your lymphocytes,
your T cells, your natural killer cells, which are lymphocytes subsets,
are what kill cancer cells. So, that's the whole idea of
saying that. So, even when I say try to get your protein levels up to the
to the, you know, grams of protein per body weight, what your desired body weight is,
instead of something you need to obsess about, you necessarily need to
cult on a daily basis either just go, oh boy, I just want to kind of look at
my I guess I am only like 30 grams of protein a day. I need to bump that up. I
need to start eating some chicken or some beef every day and
and get that up there. You don't need to necessarily
count it every day and be obsessive about it. I don't want that for anybody. We have
to stay in balance and keep our focus on doing what's right.
But our focus shouldn't be on the the acts of doing right. Our focus needs to be
on our heavenly brother and just ask him to develop that relationship with him and be asking him
to convince you about what you need to tweak and what you need to change and what you need to do.
And you use guidance through, you know, us and me as best as possible and
honors and and you don't love to become
anxious or obsessive in anything that you do, whether it's
dietary or something that's or anything. So just
guarding you against that. Last week we answered a couple questions for me regarding
electrically recharging depleted cells. So if we missed last week we were talking about
cell, your cell membranes hold a charge that charges
measurable actually. That's called your phase angle to measure your you can measure your phase
angle for those who you know, days below by, used to come in our office, used to measure your phase
angle. You mentioned the PEMF was good technology to assist with this. I have a beaver. A beaver is
a PEMF machine. So that I have been using twice per day, more than an evening. I found two interviews
on your blog library referencing the beaver and your guests categorize it into the category of PEMF.
That's right because the beaver is a post electromagnetic field. It's called a low ghost,
post electromagnetic field machine. My doctor recommended it to improve microcirculation,
but does beaver also work to electrically recharge depleted low voltage cells.
The answer is yes, that's exactly what the beaver does. That's exactly what a PEMF machine does.
That's really the benefit made benefit of a PEMF machine. Two water questions and a mineral question
today context. A relatively wide recently spent two weeks at the carfield clinic for colorectal cancer
treatment. While there, the clinic provided alkalized water produced by a kingkin machine.
In researching your site, I found two articles where you discouraged the consumption of alkalized water.
Number one, if one is consuming a healthy diet, clean, balanced, organic, not factory
process, and not relying on alkalized water to compensate for an otherwise poor diet,
is there benefit to consuming slightly alkalized water produced by an ionizer?
Number one is that should I use alkalized water at all? This alkalized water
alkalized my body. That's really the question because you've heard that cancer
grow in an alkaline environment. Cancer grows in a acidic environment. That is kind of better
dogma in the alternative world. Number one, I totally disagree with that. Dogma, I totally
disagree with that statement. Cancer does not grow because the environment is acidic,
or does it stop growing because the environment is alkaline?
Cancer is growing because the cell is defective in the DNA replication piece.
That's why cancer grows. So, something got inside the cell,
damaged the DNA. It goes into rapid replication and replicates cells that are rapidly replicating.
And the rate of that replication is the speed in which the cancer grows, the rate in which
the cancer grows. So, and a quote-unquote aggressive cancer has a higher replication rate.
Maybe it's replicating every day. Maybe it's replicating every hour. That would be very aggressive
cancer. So, or maybe the cancer is replicating very slowly. So, and our goal is to stop it
from replicating or to slow the replication cycle. You're slowing the growth of the cancer.
That's the idea. Though anytime cells are rapidly replicating, they're highly metabolic.
Take a lot of energy. It takes energy in order to do that. When a cell produces energy
and inside that cell is a warehouse of different small little organs called organelles
that do different things. What is mitochondria? Are organelles that produce energy?
Well, it also produces a lot of waste. So, that waste is then exited through the cell membrane
and into the extracellular space where the lymphatic system then carries it away. But since cancer
is rapidly replicating, it's producing a lot more waste typically than your lymph system can carry away.
And when the cancer is producing a lot more waste, that waste is more acidic typically. So,
cancer is growing in an acidic environment because it's producing an acidic environment.
But it's not because it's acidic that it grows. It's not something outside the cell that's
causing the cell to grow and to replicate. So, that's a medical model. It's not something outside
of you that's causing a problem. It's something inside of you. Same thing with the cells. It's not
something outside of the cell that's causing the problem. It's something that's inside the cell that's
causing the problem, and the nucleus in the case of cancer, but it is producing a lot of acidic
waste. So is it good to alkalize my body? Well, yes, well, how would it alkalize a cancer? Well,
I would increase the ability for that cancer to for that site where the cancer is growing to be
able to detoxify. So how do I help lip flow to the area and lip to drain that out? So there's
not a, you know, waste layer of acidic waste layer that that hinders my immune system's
ability to get lymphocytes and natural killer cells in there to kill the cancer. Well, you need
to help with detoxification pathways. And you don't just detoxify through the lymph. You have to
that lip desk to be carried out back to the blood stream the arterial system, the venous system,
and then that goes back to the liver and has to exit through the liver phase one, phase two,
phase three pathways, and then through the gut and then to the toilet. So that's why I wrote seven
phases of detoxification to help understand the chemical through that process. It might drink baking,
so which is much more alkaline than alkaline water. Is that going to help alkalize my tissue site?
Well, yes, if my cancer is in my lower esophagus or my stomach,
is that, but the idea is you have to detoxify. You have to get rid of that acidic slime layer
in order to be able to get things flowing so that your lymphocytes can get in there. So it's not
just a matter of changing the pH of the area. It's a matter of getting rid of that detoxify that. So
even if I have stomach cancer, would it be advisable to drink alkaline water, would it be advisable to
drink sodium by carbonate baking soda? No, I don't think so. I don't think the purpose is to change the
pH of that area. The purpose is to help get rid of that waste, not to change the pH of it.
I think the fact that waste is acidic is really a non-issue.
Besides the fact, it's just like a physiology. If I drink baking soda, if I eat baking soda,
I would be alkalizing the stomach. Is that even advisable?
Drinking alkalized water and alkalizing my stomach and defeating the purpose of my stomach
cells, the bridal cells in my stomach, producing hydrochloric acid to digest my food. I'm alkalizing my
stomach, which is increasing the risk of high Hylori infection in my stomach and in my Dewanum.
An increase in the risk of Hylori in the gut, which then could spread throughout my body,
which Hylori is the top five causes of the coronary heart disease and arterial spirulosis.
It just doesn't make it tricky. Alkalizing your stomach makes zero physiology
sense whatsoever. It's zero. So I just totally disagree with using alkalized water.
I'm stepping on a lot of toes, but it just does not make any physiological sense to me whatsoever.
And you're actually probably producing more ill health with a person.
Now, the question is going to go on here because I have to answer this point.
Number two, one of the other advertised benefits of the king and system is that it pumps the
water full of hydrogen. Now, that's a totally different game. So hydrogenated water is totally
different than alkalized water. So this machine may actually hydrogenate the water too.
I have all four using hydrogenated water. So if you want to use hydrogenated water
all for that. But there's machines that use hydrogenate that will hydrogenate your water
without alkalizing your water. So I would highly recommend that if that's something that you consider.
I don't tell people to go get hydrogen water. We were into that for a period of time and then all
first came out. It can be costly to get a machine to do that. And I don't know completely the
benefits. I know the one machine that I just got an email about yesterday or the day before that they
did some internal studies with cancer patients and saw some benefits. But I have to take a closer look
at that. That's a different thing than alkalized water. So yes, I have got a fan of alkalized water,
not a fan of drinking baking soda. But it's so. And you can look at about H. Playlorion,
the case did a couple of long pulse long back. I work at hard a ground deed and avoiding EMS,
but I want to do everything I can. Good. Last week you addressed a question about mineral supplements
and advocated the clear multiband. I found that there's also a clear multiband plus on the store.
Okay, so the difference between clear multiband and clear multiband plus is that clear multiband plus has
a few other things in it. And one of the things that clear multiband plus has in it that clear multiband
does not is iodine. Now, there's a lot of controversy about iodine. So if a person has hypo thyroid
isn't. So they have, they have low thyroid. It's classified as either primary hypo thyroidism,
meaning that they have low thyroid production, but they do not have an autoimmune thyroid
called Hashimoto's. So if you have antibodies to thyroglobulin or TPO antibodies that are elevated,
then you have Hashimoto's or Graves if you have type of thyroid. So those people in the thyroid
category, anybody with hypo, primary hypo thyroid, Graves or Hashimoto's should not take iodine.
Now, we know again that's controversial because almost almost every alternative doctor
and many, many mainstream doctors will tell people to take iodine for their thyroid. However,
study after study after study has come out and people have not read those studies.
And if you want to go into detail about iodine and thyroid, go to the courses and go to
the autoimmune course and look at, I think it's the module eight that's all on the thyroid and I go
into depth so on once you look at that yourself. So I am recommending that you do clear multimin,
not the clear multimin. When you were sick, did you go through a period where you had energy
and tell you got up and took everything you had just to do your daily routine of life?
Yeah, I mean, I had days where I was absolutely wasted and I couldn't even sit at my desk and do
work and I had to sit in, sit down in a lazy boy chair and relax. So that's what my staff do
that I was not doing well is what I was doing as therapy in my office.
What I was supposed to be working. So there was a lot of days like that.
So, yes. Now, can there be reasons like having fluid on your lungs or having fluid
asides built up in your abdominal cavity that couldn't cause that? Yes. Can there be other
reasons like anemia? That's the most common cause fatigue is overwhelming fatigue is anemia.
So you want to investigate those reasons. Now, this is the same person that asked the question,
I believe, that just got their lung drainage. So I'm curious. And if you feel like that's
any better after getting that done? I have been doing high dose vitamin C. At first, I felt so
much better the next day. In the last three or four weeks, I feel worse. The hand is more swollen
under my ribcage. Liver area is really swollen or sore. Do you think this is affecting the
cancer? I have a sponsor by liver. Why would it bother this far into the treatments as I've been doing
since July 50 grams was doing twice a week, once a week? Because cancer could just change and sometimes
you just have to change up therapies. So you might have just reached a plateau of dose and just your
body can take it. You're not detoxifying it so that you might actually be getting the toxic dose.
So when you're doing this high of grams, you think, oh, vitamin C, that's fantastic. You're getting
50 grams in right into your bloodstream. You might lose its benefits when your tissues are
completely saturated and you're not able to get that out. And then when you take another dose
and you're already saturated, that can be pressure on your liver. Remember what I say, what I've always
said, too much of a good thing can be a bad thing. So to me, if it was me, I'd pray about that and
say maybe I just need to calm down a little bit on that and just back off on that. We'd stop doing
it for several weeks, two or a month to see if your body just settles out and maybe do want to get
it in another month or so. I'll just calm down on that because you might just kind of be out of
toxic dose. Brad, due to its chronic membership, welcome going into surgery tomorrow is the
advanced healing program the best for surgery recovery. So I think you're talking about the
RIFE programs. I do have, we have a dog blog post on surgery. You might want to look at that because
there are some specific RIFE programs you might want to follow after surgery. Also after watching
the RIFE tutorial and frequently asked question videos, the information is a little conflicting. You say
you want people to snuggle with the hammerball. 0 to 18 inches away from them in bed. Jason, I think
you mean Jake and Stadeford, Jake and Turing. It's Jake.
With true RIFE says that the jack hammer amplifier, the effect of the hammerball is magnified 256 times
and it can be placed under the bed. I would prefer the under the bed approach since I'm a
light sleeper, but I have a sizable tumor with lung metastasis, your recommendation. So understand
many, many of the videos that I have made over the years was prior to true RIFE coming out with the
jack hammer amplifier. This is a new piece of equipment as in the last summer. So prior to the jack
hammer amplifier, I told everybody you should just snuggle with your right ball. You need to snuggle
with the ball. But personally, I don't use the jack hammer. I just snuggle with my right
and I snuggle with my right every night. It sustains my stomach every night.
And most people in this call probably in that same situation. We didn't start including the jack hammer
and tell just last year that it came out. So a lot of people don't have the jack hammer. Most of my
patients don't have this piece. Do you need it? No. However, if you want to sleep with the ball
under the bed, then you need it. So if you have it, you can sleep with it under your bed. You can
put it under your bed. So that is the conflicting information. It's only conflicting because you're
using another piece of equipment. So if you add the jack hammer to your ball, then you could put the
ball under the bed. You don't have to sleep with snuggle with it. And that will solve your problem.
So yes, that's exactly what you can do. Can you talk about caster oil packs? I have all the
materials, but have it hesitant to do it. How do they work? How do they help someone with cancer?
Especially is cancer if cancer is in the liver. So I recommend caster oil packs over the liver.
Mainly that's all I recommend is the user caster oil packs over the liver. Caster oil packs just
help the flow. They'll help decrease the viscosity of the bile. They're by helping the bile flow
through the common bile duct. And into the gall bladder, it out into the tomato. So that's how
caster oil packs work. Even if you have cancer in the liver, even if you don't have cancer in the liver,
they help move things through the liver. So yes, go ahead and use them. We can have instructions
in your manual. I recently got a GI map and bichotoxin test results. GI map, no H-glular issues.
Ooh, that's good. Opportunistic bacterium balances. Yes. Staph aureus, streptococcus, low levels of
secretory IgA and occult blood. So this is inflammation in the gut. And you have some bacteria in the
gut. So I have to look at your protocol that I have you on. First of all, I'd probably be thinking of
endographis and gerberine for these. What I would do, your cult blood has to do this person
as colon cancer. So that's to be expected. But I would think that those are the kind of things I
would think of with this. The bichotox test shows occultoxin A, high, but not showing any
mill mold in your house. So the bichotox test doesn't test for mold in your house. So I did
say that you don't notice any mold in your house. You really want to get some mold plates to see
if you have mold in your house. If your ocultoxin test is high. So where you get ocultoxin A,
ocultoxin. So understand, again, the bichotox test is not testing for mold. It's testing for the
toxins that mold produces. So when you have high levels of ocultoxin A, that means you were
exposed to a mold that produces that that bichotoxin. Now that mold that produces that bichotoxin
is commonly found in some foods that is very commonly found in mold that would be in buildings
and in your home and things like that. So it is probably the most common bichotoxin to be elevated
because we're often exposed to mold in homes and buildings in schools and everybody's bedded as,
you know, especially schools. I could still smell the mold in my memory of my school when I was in
great school. Yeah, in my case, there's no mold in my home that I'm aware of, but there's meditation hall
in the field house where I take kids to play that is loaded with mold and I had to actually leave
that place and couldn't go there and I haven't gone back for, you know, probably over a month now.
Okay, so when you have elevated ocultoxins, that end of the toxins of that mold production.
So you still have to detoxify those. So those are poisons that that mold produced that are in your
body still. So the reason why you get your home tested and get your, you know, you can smell them and
you can, you kind of got a pretty good idea. You have to do that investigation of, okay, where did I get
this? Because I don't want current exposure. Because if you're going to detoxify that, that I like
that, that's what I like about our clear talks product. If you're going to detoxify that and you have
current exposure, but, you know, you're never going to really detoxify. The toxins that mold
produces are poisonous to everybody and they can really make us ill and ochre toxin A is a cancer
causing agent. So pulling that out of your body, but also, you know, making sure that you don't have
hidden current exposure. So if you, like you said, and you went to these certain places and you
could smell molds, you had to exit those areas, do not go there again. And maybe inform, you know,
higher powers that they should get that clean up because other people are getting sick too. It's not
going to be just you. So these are very dangerous things. And not just as just because they're
our, our carcinogens, but they can make, they can cause inflammation in the brain. They can cause
all sorts of really serious problems. So mold is a serious issue that needs to be dealt with. So
detoxing it is the thing. So you're detoxing. These are poisons. This isn't the mold. This isn't mold
in your system now. It's the toxins that the mold produces that's in your system. And you detox
it with key layers. So, and binders. So really, any binders and any key layers can really help pull
these things out. And I didn't look at your, your protocol, but you might already be on some of those
things. So I'll look at your protocol tomorrow and email you. I think there's anything else
for you to change. Thank you. Dr. Thomas, a sick freed author of cancer as a metabolic disease
promotes the ketogenic diet and at time glutamate restriction to not feed cancer. He has coined the
term metabolic ecology, thoughts on this approach. Seems he has excellent results and affects cancer
cells and others. So, yes, so understand ketogenic diet again is something that's your
strongly restricted any glucose in the body. And that's the balance of, you know, looking at
getting a glucometer and measuring your glucose. Now, if you're getting truly into ketosis and your
goal is to get into ketosis, you can't just use a glucose monitor. You have to use a ketone monitor.
Then it gets a little trickier and there's a little bit of a learning curve to learn how to measure
that and to get yourself into ketosis if that is a person's goal. Most practitioners, though, believe
like I do, that it's not even necessary to get into ketosis. Really, if you could get your blood
glucose down below 80, you can do the same thing as what he is doing. Matter of fact, there's some
research that's going on right now through a group that I follow that is using Dr. Thomas as a member
in the research group and that's what they are finding. So even under his guidance, they are actually
finding you get the exact same benefits as trying to get into ketosis as just getting the glucose levels
down. Now understand, it could be hard to do. I mean, it is very difficult to stay on a ketogenic
diet and it is even more difficult to truly stay in ketosis and most people end up giving up. The
younger you are, the easier it is to do that. As we age, it's even more difficult to truly get into
ketosis and it can be difficult as we've talked about on these Zoom calls, even eating a pretty
perfect diet. Many times it's hard to get your glucose levels down below 100 for some people because
glucose is not just a product of your diet. It's a product of your cell membranes and it's a product
of your pain grease. So there's a lot of different pieces to the puzzle. I've had over the years I've
had diabetic patients that would go on a full ketogenic diet and they still, I was just mind boggles
that it's not eating any glucose and any carbohydrates whatsoever and we couldn't
tear glucose levels below 150. So it was like, my gosh, it's more complex than that. Now the younger
person is trying to do that. It's a little bit easier to do. Should I be taking glutamate as a
supplement? No, absolutely not. It's really a glutamate restriction that you want to do so glutamate
can feed cancer in energy. You don't want to take glutamate as a supplement, especially it's even
more important not to take glutamate as a supplement if you have colon or colorectal cancer.
That's the epithelial cells in your colon prefer glutamate or replication. Questions on the chat,
high doctor cutters. Today I learned that Dr. Hancock will likely take me as a patient because
of my situation. Good news. From him, in his office, I learned about Dr. Reddy, an open-minded
ecologist in the Atlanta area. So our moving plan is going forward. Praise God. That's fantastic.
I have noticed a couple of times lately while holding on to my right bulb that I become electric
during certain parts of the program. So when I touch on what I buzz and slightly shock them,
is this usual and say, yes, it's very usual and very same. So it does can give you an electrical
charge. So we talk about, you know, adding, you know, this person was talking about trying to use a
PDF to increase cell charge. Well, your right does increase cell charge too. You are getting
some electrical benefits with that. If I have chemo in the afternoon, is it okay to do a flip-back
in the morning before chemo? Yeah, I'd say no problem whatsoever with that. Sure. I had my first
chemo, one of three, three weeks apart. Last Wednesday, I have some side effects, but I feel much
better than I would have expected. I could tell that the detoxing makes me feel better and I am
grateful. However, I can feel my kidneys as well as a weird air traffic pressure at times. Might
be getting bogged down. And should I be using other or additional detoxing? I am doing half over
Soda. Two of these coffee animals, castoral impacts on the liver, be about 40 minutes a day,
footpath, three to four times a week, rebounder, a few minutes a day, supplements. All these are good,
maybe adds a little bit of mild exercise. That can be good for the brain too.
So yeah, you're doing well. Making sure you're drinking putty of water, having all good
bowel movements. Do you recommend filtering city tap water? Absolutely positively. You do not
want fluoride, you don't want chlorine. Two poisons fluoride is just criminal that they're still
put into the water system. You definitely have to get that out. You do not want to be drinking.
What filter do you recommend? You can use reverse osmosis. You can use a burky filter.
Typically, a simple carbon filter will take out the fluoride and chlorine,
but a carbon filter will take out heavy metals. If you have heavy metals in the water,
that's where you have to use reverse osmosis. Some people say, well, reverse osmosis causes dead water.
It doesn't have any minerals in it. Yeah, but you're not drinking your water for your minerals.
In the minerals that you do get in your water are earth-bound milling minerals. They're not the type
of minerals that are good for you anyhow. So that whole argument just does not hold water.
Other than taking it. Our water would come from Atlanta. Yeah, you need to get out. I would
I'd recommend reverse osmosis. We have reverse osmosis here at the office. Even though we have
well water at the office. Tested fire and nitrates. Nitrates so we better reverse osmosis here.
Our water at our home is well water and we tested it and it's good. So we do not have
the filtration unit at the office. Wouldn't it be good to add charcoal powder to a coffee
in it? I don't know. I don't know what that would be really beneficial because your coffee
in it isn't going very high up in your testicle tract. So probably not. You're not going to absorb that
anyhow. Would not hurt but caught your joke, doc Jake at St. Berk. Sorry. I stayed with the jack
hammer and the bulb right next to me because I thought I was supposed to. I zapped my wife a lot
and left one to shut. Well, that actually makes life a little more fun. So that's great.
So yeah, if you ask that question about putting it under the bed, if you have the jackhammer,
then you can put it under the bed. I was going to ask if there was anything preventing one from
snuggling with the hammer bulb connected to a jackhammer. No, except that, you know, you're
are getting a higher amplification. So you will end up with this problem that people are talking about
to people today that you're going to produce more electromagnetic electricity. So you're going to
have a charge. So electromagnetic, so when you rub your feet against, you know, on the carpet and you
touch somebody and you give them a shock, it's because you have more electrons on the surface of your
skin. And it is the same thing with if you use the right, you can develop electrons on the surface of
your skin. So when somebody touches you, they get a shock. If you're using the jackhammer,
you have an amplification of that. So you will actually produce more electrons, especially if the bulb
is right next to you and you're using the jackhammer. So some people don't like that. So I understand
I'm joking that brings a little fun to your marriage, but it's not very pleasant. So
personally, I don't use the jackhammer because I've got used to snuggling with the bulb.
So now if I was, if that bothered me at the light bothered me and stuff, I would just use the jackhammer
because the bulb underneath me, well, I slept and then that would solve that problem. The only
caution I've seen is not to touch the jackhammer, not a problem as the frequency cheddar is better than
the band. So that's just that's fun. You really don't need to, if you have the jackhammer, you don't
need to snuggle with the bulb. So other things I should be doing to combat any potential auto-immune
issues that might be happening due to the ketruda. Well, you can't really combat them until that
happened. So most people that are going to take the mutal therapy, like ketruda, that's one
brand of a mutal therapy are going to end up with an autoimmune issue. You just can't prevent that
because the whole what a mutal therapy does is it blocks the the receptor site on the T cells,
on your T cells. So your lymphocytes break down into natural killer cells into T cells. But that's
what kills kids are. Are those two things? Well, the T cells have a receptor site that that your
human body cells attached to and then it tells the T cells not to kill your body cells. So
what if you don't therapy like ketruda does is it blocks that receptor site so that your T cells will
kill the cancer. Well, they'll also kill your human body cells and you'll end up with autoimmune
like diseases. So you could get any type of inflammation. Those cuddling will be colitis,
but you're on ketruda. So you just got to deal with it when you get it and just try to heal the
colon and you can't necessarily prevent it. Thank you for the admission to not obsess about diets.
I struggle with that. Thank you for pointing us back to the word. You're very welcome now.
I have a reverse osmosis system in my kitchen with minerals added. We are out of well. Should I
continue with the minerals? It really depends on the source of the minerals. So
I would have to know the system. I know some of those systems have like a tube thing,
like a filter thing that adds minerals, but they're really crap. Sorry, crappy forms of minerals.
Remember, your minerals should be as if you're eating vegetables or
or grass-fed beef or grass-fed meats and chicken. Those minerals are double bonded to the
amino acid. So that's why I do not recommend the liquid for minerals that are out there. I don't
recommend, you know, a lot of the most of the products you can buy at Target and Walgreens and stuff
like that because they're just garbage minerals like E dirt. We are not created to eat dirt. We're
created to eat the plants or eat the vegetables or eat the animals that are eating the plants and
the vegetables. It's already broken down by the plants to a double bonded to an amino acid and then
eat that. That's how we absorb it. So it's a mineral canister added to the RO system from the company.
I would give rid of that. See if you can eliminate that. It's definitely, it's definitely
just a mineral. It's definitely a first one mineral. So I'd give rid of that. One of the symptoms of
colitis and when might it become active and illness? It would be just pain in your gut.
So colitis is inflammation of the gut so you could have pain in the gut. You could have pain after
you eat. You could have bloody stool. There's different symptoms. It's all serious. The colitis is
serious. Again, don't focus on what could be. So, you know, if any
admonition I could give all of you just to kind of keep your focus on the Lord. And yes, if something
happens, then we'll deal with it and ask him how to deal with it. You can ask me how to deal with it.
But don't focus on what could be what might be in a bad sense. Focus on the possibility.
Call and punish us in first Corinthians. There's anything that's good, anything that's
holy, anything that's right, anything that's worthy of your admonition. Focus on those things.
That's, you know, the world is horrible all around us. It's easy to get our eyes off of Christ
and our eyes on to the problems. Let's not do that. Let's notish each other daily to keep our eyes
focused on what's positive, what's good, what's holy, and work on those things. If you're getting
some stuff at crappy, after you eat them, then make sure you're getting digestive enzymes,
make sure you have lots of supplements that you're taking. So just look at anything that could
be irritating your stomach and tweak your diet around that. Thanks, everyone, for the prayers. My double
best deck to be met smoothly. For the next day, I felt fine, other than just uncomfortable.
Everyone around me says it's because I met such good shake and doing my program this last year.
Now, onto the next phase. I'm grateful for that one. Praise God, it's a good note. And done.
Though that I'll be prayed for all of you, and I do just ask that you guys pray for each other.
And keep your focus on what I'm priced and all that he's given us and be grateful and thankful
in all things until next week. Let's see you then.